hi there I'm Sultan from University of
Waterloo I will be presenting our work
on distance recovery problem this is
Joint work with strong finishing that
Professor David Ruff from CMU and
Professor Hong yanjang from Waterloo
imagine there is an unknown Point as in
high dimensional space and you are asked
to locate this point
the only information you can get is a
set of other points and why and the
distance between s and Y
we ask what is the minimum size of the
set why in order to locate this point
another way to describe this problem is
to use a two-player communication game
we have Bob which is the article
embedded with an input sequence as an
auditions function d the player of Alice
wants to guess the sequence s by
selecting a set of queries and sending
them to Bob and Bob Returns the distance
between the input sequence s and the
query y
the queries can be either adaptive or
non-adaptive and finally ILS output her
guess of the sequence s
the goal of Alice is to make us feel at
queries as possible now we have to
require complexity for Alice to win the
game you can pause the video for 10
seconds to think of this problem
you may have noticed that require
complexity May depends on the distance
functions
in fact this problem is not new on some
distances
they have been started even dating back
to 1960s and the results could be found
on some pure mathematical journals
for example if one looks into recovery
for having distances
it's related to learning problems such
as through coin weighing and group
testing
Norm the current complexity for
Mastermind game is known there are also
works on M estimators
but all these distancing Matrix are
decomposable that is the distance
between two sequences can be written as
a sum of some function f on each
coordinate of the sequence
we would like to initiate the study of
the recovery problem on non-decomposable
distances
so now the compostable distances
sequences are not required to be aligned
coordinated by coordinate instead the
distance is defined by some implicit
optimal alignment as per dynamic
programming
there are large class distance Matrix
fitting to this category for example we
have the added distance DTW distance
fresh a
Earth more distance
ulum distance cascaded on
due to the time constraint I will be
mainly focusing on talking about the PTW
distance but more results on other
distance could we find in our full paper
to introduce DTW distance we will first
introduce a notion of rounds and
expansions
rounds of a sequence X are the maximum
substrings with a single repeated
character
we use the notion number of rounds to
denote the number of runs in a sequence
extending and its runs in a sequence
gives the expansion of that sequence to
give example
we have the sequence X
how many rounds in are there in in this
X
there are five
zero one zero one one and zero
um X1 bar and X2 bar are there two
expansions of X by extending the second
row and the third wrong in x
next we Define the L1 cos between two
aligned expansions of X and Y which is
the L1 basically there are one Norm
distance
for instance the cost between X bar as 1
bar and X2 bar is one
so the DTW distance is defined as the
minimum cost over all possible pairs of
extensions to continue the running
sample given X and Y the digital
distance is zero because there exists
expansion of X and Y are the same
here we need to listen RI of this talk
for the sake of time we cannot present
all the details and results we obtained
we refer you to the full paper for more
technical details if you are interested
in our work
why interesting property we observe
about this recovery problem on
non-decomposable distances is there
exist sequences that are cannot be
distinguished by any distance queries
um for this observation we derive
three levels of recovery guarantees
we presented the lower bounds for the
recovery problem according to different
guarantees
then we started the adaptive strategies
to recover from distance queries
interestingly there exists a general
framework for all non-decomposable
distances
we also obtain a list of results for now
non-adaptive queries
I will present our results on TW
distance
finally I will briefly mention some
applications and open problems of this
work
if you revisit this problem you may
notice that it is not super clear what
does it mean by Alice wins the game
ideally we would like Alice to Output S
Prime equals to s
which means the exact recovery of the
input sequences
but this is not always possible
especially for some non-decomposable
distances
and digiwa gives a perfect example
showing this
if we set the input sequence as as 0 1 0
1 0
when Alice car is bought with a sequence
0 1 1 0 1 0 then as we can see that we
have seen in the running sample the DTW
distance between these two sequences is
zero
and S is not equal to y i but Alice can
hardly get more information from this
query
in fact
we can prove that
this s and Y I are not distinguishable
by any binary sequences
by this interesting observation
therefore we derive the three levels of
recovery guarantees
the strongest guarantee is to recover
the exact input sequence
in cases that exact recovery is not
possible we categorize the input surveys
in two equivalence classes and look for
algorithms to recover a sequence that is
in the same equivalent class as the
input sequence
the last one is to recover any sequence
with zeroing distance to input which is
a guarantee provided by the general
adaptive recovery framework
this one is the weakest since the zero
distance does not necessarily mean two
sequences are not distinguishable
foreign
of our problem
now let's move on to more technical
details
we obtain a number of results on added
distance DTW and fresher distance with
optimal or near optimal current
complexity guarantee
first I would like to show you the lower
bounds of the recovery problem
let's start from a trivial Bound for
exact recovery which requires Toyota
Omega and quarries
the Toyota Omega notation has a logging
Factor
this lower bound is obtained by an
information theoretical proof
first a current result is an integer in
om which is the information address can
get in a single query from Bob
and there are two to the End plus one
possible input sequences in the search
space
by information Theory we cannot lower
bound with an overlug inquiries
further if Alice is allowed to use
randomized algorithms we can actually
get the same Bound by a reduction from a
two party one-way communication game
called index
for equivalence class recovery
the lower bound is exactly Omega n
but the information theoretical proof
does not apply here
this is because the existence of
indistinguishable sequences
as shown in this Illustrated figure
the input space has been split into
blocks of indistinguishable sequences
the size of the search space is no
longer 2 to the N plus one
or small the size of the reduced search
space is very hard to characterize
so we have to find another way to prove
this lower bound
the key inside behind our approved
technique is to find the set of
sequences such that distinguishing them
already needs at least
Omega inquiries
in the proof we use the known technique
of DTW MSS reduction
I will skip the details but the takeaway
here is Computing DTW distance between
two sequences is equivalent to Computing
and optimization problem called MSS
the MSS problem is instantiated by these
two sequences and the same MSS instance
can imply the same DW distance
with this reduction the first
observation we made is that for a pair
of input sequences with certain patterns
they can be only distinguished by a
query with certain number of ROMs
this pattern is found by observing
certain construction of the MSS instance
so for example
this pair of inputs can only be
distinguished by queries with a number
of runs between 4 and 10. we know that
this interval is the constant
keeping this in mind we show it is able
to find o and many pairs of input
sequences with that pattern
such that distinguishing them requires
Omega and disjoint queries
this proves the ideas of the claim
then I would like to show you some
interesting upper bounds on the current
complexity
the first one is a general framework for
distance recovery which works for end
distances
the framework is based on a Technique we
call coordinate descent
like I said it is sub-optimal and
requires contract number of requirements
we can only get the recovery guarantee
of zero distance to input
you can regard this coordination as an
Adaptive optimization framework
what is the loss function in this
framework
we can think of the loss function as the
distance metric and our goal is to
reduce the loss to zero
so what we do is to change the current
required sequence
coordinate by coordinate as long as we
find one to decrease the loss function
and then we repeat this process until we
achieve the goal and output the result
state it more formally we Define a step
on step operation
which is defined as per distances
for example I'll add a distance
a step function is to add or delete or
change your character
we know that one step operation can
reduce the loss function at most one
finding a step operation to reduce the
loss function would require at most o
and many queries
since the length of the sequence is at
most om
then we need to perform oh and many step
operations
therefore the overall current complexity
for this framework is in square
again this coordinate decent framework
is stop optimal
but it fits all
non-decombatable distances
for the specialized instantiations are
added distance DTW distance and fresher
distance
we have adaptive strategies that only
use all inquiries which matches the
lower bounds of the query complexity
we know that the special properties of
the distances are required
next I will guide you into our results
on DW distance our first
briefly mention our results on
non-adaptive equivalence class recovery
and since the sequencing
distinguishability assumes querying with
only binary sequence later I will show
you a more interesting results that if
one is allowed to query with a slightly
larger upper path then we can actually
achieve exact recovery with optimal
query complexity
so if you are looking for ways to
exactly recover from this double
distance with only binary queries I have
shown you the hardest result by this
counter example
if we are looking for equivalence class
recovery I have showing you the lower
bounds which is Omega n
now I can tell you in the upper bound of
the equivalence class recovery which is
also oh and
which matches the car complexity lower
bound
we show this by a constructive proof
the camera based these two groups of
virus zeros and ones
they are zero one complementary
the essential idea of constructing this
set of queries is to cover all possible
numbers wrongs for n lens sequences
we prove if two sequences cannot be
distinguished by the query side then
they are not distinguishable by any
binary queries
we can categorize the properties of the
sequences which are not distinguishable
by these card set for example they
should have the same number of runs and
have the same first round and last round
with these features we can do DCW MSS
reduction and apply a case analysis
note that we have a pair of input
sequences as an S Prime
we show that for any given query queue
the two MSS instance
mssq and MSS S Prime Q they can give the
same solution
this implies
we have the same DTW distance
this also shows they are now
distinguishable by any queries
for details about this case analysis we
refer you to our full paper
so far we have shown that if Alice is
only allowed to make queries on zero one
not for bad
then the best results you can get is to
use all inquiries to recover to the
equivalence class
but interestingly if valence is allowed
to query from up or bad with 4
characters 0 1 1 3 and 2 5. she can
exactly recover the input sequence as
with M plus two colors
again first I will show you our car
reconstruction and show you a sketch of
how this is achieved
let a denote the character one third and
B denotes the character two-fifths
we Define the ith query Qi as the first
and minus I characters filling with a
and the following I characters of B
this consists of n queries and the
entire course that contains the single
zero query and a single one query as
well
you may wonder why we have to use
one-third and two-fifths in fact a more
General result is possible as long as a
and b are called prime numbers and this
inequality out
but why this set of query can work for
exact recovery
to see this we know that the exact
sequence recovery with DTW distance
queries requires one to find a way to
encode sufficient information for the
query and to identify the implicit
alignment or the matching
between the sequences
which are the two challenges for solving
this problem
to see why this would work let's examine
some properties of these queries
the first property of this query is that
all of the qis are monotonic sequences
that is first query sequence it's jth
character should be less than or equal
to its J plus one character
with this property we can guarantee
input uniqueness which means that each
character in The query sequence should
be matched to exactly one character in
the input sequence
we show that the monotonic sequence
construction strategy implies input
uniqueness
this property is proved by using
triangle inequality such that if there
exists a character in The query sequence
that matches to more than one character
in the input sequence we can reduce the
edge
and obtain a new matching with less DTW
cards by repeatedly repeatedly doing so
input uniqueness is one characterization
of the optimal matching when using our
chord set
what is the benefit of having inputed
nucleus
that is actually the way we encode
information which solves the Challenger
one
the two figures are the DTW matchings
with two neighboring queries
you can notice that we both follow
included links
when we change from query q1 to Q2 by
changing the second last character from
A to B
the DW distance query results are only
changed from y minus a to 1 minus B
seems to know about the query sequences
by doing differentiation we can obtain
whether the second last character in s
is zero or one
so input uniqueness guarantees a single
character in The query only matches to
one input character
but how do we know if there are
characters in the input that maps to
multiple characters in The query
this question leads to our second design
choices
we would like to have the query sequence
to be zero one preferred
that is
as you may have noticed
all characters in our query sequences
are less than one half
since matching a
or B to zeros in the input sequence has
a lower cost than matching to one
then everyone in input sequence s only
matches to a single character in q y
this design tells us the structure of
the DCW matching
so essentially these two properties of
the query sequences can help us recover
from DTW distance
we also use prime and coprime numbers to
encode and decode information
we develop algorithms to show how the
recovery can be done
we may still have questions about how
could we guarantee that changing the
query sequence will now change the
matches between the two sequences
we Define the notion of isomorphic DW
matching and we can prove that with our
current stat the matching between the
input and all car sequences is the same
you know this is just a bird of view
sketchable proof for more technical
details we refer you to the longer
version of our paper archive
although I have presented our results
with DTW distance we know that all these
results can be naturally generalized to
ptdw distance
in our paper we have another set of
interesting results on added distance
and fresh air distance with either
optimal or near optimal complexities
so far you might think that these
non-decomposable distance recovery
problems are weird Curiosities that have
no conservable applications
however the initial motivation for us to
think about this problem is from a
diversary robust machine learning
as you know
there are machine learning tasks applied
on display domains for example natural
language processing or NLP models
processes textual data
in adversary of machine learning one
considerable anniversary that can make
human imperceptible changes to the input
so as to for the model or the classifier
on IOP input domain
a meaningful adversal perturbation can
be defined by added instance
an example is showing the figure below
an anniversary can change brain in the
last sentence to rain
where the added distance is one but the
prediction flips
a common way to achieve certified
robustness against this diversary attack
is to guarantee the lipseness of the
model
but lipsiousness is defined over
continuous domain therefore we need a
mapping that Maps the points in the
Discord domain to The Continuous domain
which is actually related to the
boarding battings
furthermore
we like this mapping to be information
preserving to guarantee the model
accuracy
we know that our non-adaptive query
recovery strategy can naturally yield
away to this type of Machinery in your
business
I would also like to mention about the
open problems that we do not have
Perfect Solutions
first I'll add a distance the lower
bound which is the one given by the
information theory is omega
while the best upper Bound for
non-adaptive car race is squared if we
are restricted to a binary alphabet
we would like to close the quadratic gap
between lower bound and upper Bound in
the Square complexity
second
on TW distance as I have shown we have
to use two extra characters to achieve
the optimal current upper bound
but does there exist anyways to reduce
the number of X factors to 1 or is there
any honest result for the number of
extra characters
anyone who solves one of these core
problems we are happy to treat you to an
all-you-can-eat sushi dinner in Waterloo
thank you very much for listening please
scan the QR code for the links to our
full paper if you are interested in this
work
please do not hesitate to connect with
ours if you have any questions
our email addresses can be found in the
paper link